étude, entre 85 et 2015, le
rythme d'urbanisation a été cinq
foies plus importants que le
rythme de protection.
Normand Grondin.
TOMMY MONTPETIT, directeur de la
conservation, Ciel et Terre
- Les milieux humides sont
absolument nécessaires....
nécessaires à la vie,
c'est la base de la vie,
les milieux humides. Donc,
ils sont extrêmement importants.
Ils font de la captation
de carbone puis ils abritent
une biodiversité absolument
hallucinante.
- Des milieux naturels
d'un coté de la rue, des
habitations neuves de l'autre :
le boisé du Tremblay,
à Longueuil, a diminué de 15 %
au cours des dernières années.
Est-ce qu'on continue
de le développer ou
on protège ce qu'il reste
de milieux naturels?
C'est toute la communauté
métropolitaine de Montréal,
la CMM, qui est maintenant
aux prises avec ce genre
de conflits.
- Malheureusement, on est rendus
à une étape dans l'histoire
où tous les milieux naturels
de la région sont importants.
- Un groupe de chercheurs arrive
à la même conclusion :
la grande région de Montréal ne
peut plus se permettre de perdre
ses derniers milieux naturels.
JÉRÔME DUPRAS, prof. Départ.
sciences naturelles, UQO
- Beaucoup de territoires
publics, donc, la propriété
des villes ou de gouvernements,
ont été protégés déjà,
mais depuis 2012,
les gains en aires protégées
sont de 0,0001 %.
- En 2011, la CMM s'est engagée
à protéger 17 % de son
territoire d'ici 2031.
Selon l'étude, on atteint
tout juste 10 %,
10 ans plus tard.
10 %, c'est très peu sur
un aussi grand territoire.
Mais heureusement,
le potentiel pour en faire
beaucoup plus est là.
Le problème : la majorité
de ces terrains sont privés et
leur prix pourrait être élevé.
- C'est probablement la façon
la plus évidente pour aller
augmenter la protection
de milieux naturels. Ceci dit,
ce n'est pas facile à réaliser.
- L'étude estime qu'avec une
politique d'achat de terrains
bien planifiée et en
s'attaquant à la restauration
de milliers de parcelles
de terrains endommagés,
la CMM pourrait non seulement
atteindre son objectif en 2031,
mais l'augmenter à 25 %.
Les deux principaux candidats à
la mairie de Montréal ont réagi
positivement à ces conclusions.
VALÉRIE PLANTE, candidate mairie
de Montréal, Projet Montréal
- Il y a beaucoup à faire
et je souhaite ardemment
qu'on ait une vision d'ensemble.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat, mairie
de Montréal, Ensemble Montréal
- Là, on parle de 25 % et plus.
Donc, on doit travailler
pour ça. Mais pour ça, là,
ça prend du leadership.
- Toujours selon l'étude,
le rythme d'urbanisation dans
le grand Montréal est cinq fois
plus rapide que le rythme de
protection des milieux naturels.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M